let's go come on
fatty fatty fatty Betty Betty Betty
what's cooking gang welcome back to them
hard [ __ ] feelings I'm your
host H Foley this week [ __ ] taking
the range I'm driving the bus I'm making
all this stuff all blown crazy town for
all for everybody listening and or
watching he was just going through
Instagram to find out who unfollowed him
and he ain't happy about it okay next
stop psychoville
and the fair is free how about that
Kevin James Ryan sitting across the
table from me what's up Kippy hey gang
thanks for tuning in to [ __ ]
two days ago we've been together every
single day since I've gotten a haircut I
like your hair shorter there's there's
older pictures going around with you and
you look real 80s okay so it's like it
looks like you got a toupee okay looks
weird all right camera with the photo
was but I like it like this I only get
caught yeah like I tend to keep it
shorter it's just when we get jammed up
on a road and in the back in a day today
you miss those there's you know if I
miss it by two weeks at the top at this
point now long would be bad right like
if your hair was as long as mine oh real
bad also hold on I got a lot of things
that get [ __ ] keyboard teacher give
it up for Tebow McMuffin Toby McMullen
ladies and gentlemen what's up dudes
fire away baldy
pretty good kids got my number today
folks what do you got you got beef you
were eyeball me before we go listen I
got a lot of stuff all right but this
haircut business just raises that I had
forgotten about I go to this place over
there on 57th Street to get my hair cut
outside of my neighborhood because I've
said multiple times I live in a
predominantly Dominican neighborhood and
they don't cut white people's hair
normally I know that Petco go ahead they
give it they give you like you know cool
guy Dominican haircuts and I don't you
know I'm not I can't be walking out
there with a [ __ ] chin strap and
stuff all lined up with my points
cooking chuck chuck lime I can't walk
out like that you got the Puerto Rican
flag shaping the back of your head
so I gotta go to like regular regular
hey tat your neck real quick I gotta go
to like regular guy haircut you know not
cool guy haircut I need regular white
guy middle age I need a barber shop you
know you need a barber shop around
Midtown that's where I go 50 I used to
work right around there so I would go to
work and I would find this place uh
so what's your guy's name in there Russ
I don't have a guy I jump around well
the step also to the staff after the
quarantine
it's flexible they're taking anybody
yeah so it's like very it used to be one
of those things you walk in there's like
[ __ ] 80 chairs like a lot of Chan
they were [ __ ] burning and turning I
actually got recognized last time I was
there this guy was cutting me up and the
guy behind me goes he was done his cut
he comes he's a huge fan I got thanks
the guy cut my hair was not impressed
so I got the main guy you know there's a
main guy sure thing guys changed two or
three times over the past three or four
years right I don't know if he's an
owner I don't know if it's growing up
our main guy was Alex shout out to Mr
rotelli
um we used to that's I think we were
just talking about this my family was
Charlie so you go to Charlie's get your
hair cut and then
Charlie's spell that Charlie Charlie has
an element or there's an r in there he's
a he's a dirtball yeah you got a
Charlie's Charlie Charlie whatever tell
you that I grew up with a Charlie like
proper he was called Charlie at six
seven eight nine ten hey Charlie Charlie
Kelly and they go where's the tendon bar
now no no no good good smart kid athlete
[ __ ] Stellar baseball player okay
rapper like through college whatever
okay
um
and the one teacher was like going
through roll call the first year like
junior high or whatever and he was like
he was like Charlie Kelly and it was
like tell me what you want to be called
or whatever I was like Charlie Kelly
raises and he's like yeah it's Charlie
and the guy was like 30 he's like dude I
can't call it I can't call an eighth
grader Jolly like I don't he's like you
got to be over 60. yeah wait on you
young man but
we were at Charlie's uh
we were a Charlie's organization uh and
then
Jim Charlie's brother defected and
opened up his own shop in my hometown
well it was it was just local it was
Holland Barber that's where we went it
was right there was right down next to
the Wawa okay that's where you [ __ ]
I'm not gonna grab a [ __ ] on the way
out so that's where we went but
the main guy at this one has changed so
the past two times my first time with
them was last time right with the main
guy uh when I got recognized Foley's
cutting your hair
that's pretty good it's a deep cut shout
out to God shout out to the host in
Cleveland so
um
we get so I get so is that it's that guy
right I was like maybe six weeks so I
pushed it too long right we've been out
right you know running around this
goddamn country of ours and uh
the guy I sit down and I was a little
wonky my thumbs grow in I got like like
I said multiple times I have like a baby
doll's hair it's like really thin it's
not great it's like cutting the grass at
your grandmother's house a lot of things
you got to go around sure it's a lot
going it doesn't grow great like even
the side like where they're most of it's
weeds
spray me down with rid-x or whatever
boy you got dandelion on your head
oh
[ __ ] dog [ __ ] he sits down
step in dog [ __ ] when you're walking
through gimpies
um
wait hang on we got any more you can
squeeze out of this okay go ahead
um so I sit down he starts doing like
you know he's like not happy with what
he's looking at right he's like like the
back cause I'm all it's I'm all wacky
and he's like dude you're bald man now
and he goes he goes
where'd you get your hair cut last I
went here
Penny you did it you [ __ ] did he goes
he goes who did it and I had a friend
I'm like [ __ ] you did and he's like
oh now he feels like an [ __ ] and now
I feel like an [ __ ] I gotta quit
drinking everyone's looking at them it's
a [ __ ] scene dude and I'm like I'm
like he's like oh it must have been a
long time ago like yeah yeah he's like
you waited to come back like yeah
[ __ ] I'm like hey [ __ ] Edward
jacians let's [ __ ] go zip me up will
ya get me the [ __ ] out of here cutting
you in a weed whacker but
um I feel the past few days that was
that was an aside the past few days you
have been in foleyville-esque a bit okay
um and yesterday my wife
I got to see that proper first hand
uh-huh in an all-time foleyville-esque
uh we recorded a podcast yesterday with
uh Francis Ellis yeah and uh Julio
galalate too hot good looking guys they
are kids they're really there right this
summer us they're way better looking way
more money they're really doing it those
two cool guys
you can see you're happy about this
story already I got my hand on the
trigger go ahead do you know where I'm
going
duh
what I was talking where do you think I
was talking about two different things
they were talking about nine different
things right but I don't I think your
perception of Nadine is wrong I could
I'm just gonna say sure I thought she
was mad at you because you were kind of
being very short the thing with the
phone and the looking for dinner
I don't you're trying to say I was on
her radar she said something to me what
did she say what's wrong with him really
dude z-bone this is the conversation I
don't know about it this also I was also
this could be fake news Tebow and I was
there it's not and I was also frustrated
not fresh short because the situation
you were in another world
you were mad at you were I wasn't no I
wasn't mad you were focused on something
else and you guys were dealing with
dinner I was just slow in the
conversation I was just talking oh you
were having your own cop dude we're down
there and he's we're like he's sitting
there he's smoking a cig and me and
Nadine are like oh where do you want to
go you know I was like I talked to
Francis he's like yeah nowhere around
here there's no real great restaurant
around here or whatever and uh
what are you doing
getting my water
I'll have you know so about the [ __ ]
below this story wide open so we're
sitting then I'm like where do you want
to go but me and Nadine are talking
right we're having a proper conversation
about where we're gonna go to dinner and
there's three of us in like a [ __ ]
triangle you know just the two of you
going to dinner just the two of us going
to dinner I was invited
dude you were on another planet at this
moment it was really bad I don't think I
really was to be honest with you
the way the conversation I thought I
thought you and I were having an account
I didn't realize that's how I'm saying
how much of another planet you were on
we were not having an account I thought
I think you were just checked out of the
conversation
okay
so go ahead uh we're sitting there
um and
this is outrageous
entertain you seemed to be having a lot
of fun with it by the way so we're
sitting there and he goes uh I go
we're me and Nadine are talking about
where you want to go to dinner we're
like oh we can go wherever you know do
you want to stay here do you want to
drive to Williamsburg whatever we were
going to do you know pasta tacos
whatever and he you started talking
about private school and taxes you go
that's the thing with then you gotta pay
the taxes and you gotta roll in private
school that is I was continuing the
conversation we were having with uh yeah
he was no longer there that was I I even
prefaced with like you know it's funny
to think about yeah like even if you
have the money to afford a place like no
you didn't no you didn't I'm pretty sure
I did okay
you didn't okay
um and then you also did that I go what
are you talking I was like what I had a
really in because you were out there
uh-huh you are not happy with this but
I'm not happy I just did I yeah I just
uh I think you're wrong
okay fair enough all right
well then then you started talking about
people at a club out of nowhere
again when we were still talking about
dinner and now you're off taxes you're
off private schools okay
we start I go what are you talking about
oh yeah whatever we go back to talking
about what restaurant or where we're
gonna go eat
and you're like Dad they came up to meet
the club and this and that you were
awesome then you were in another place
okay
um
I don't know what you want me to say I
don't know I thought we could have a
little fun with it that's all keep going
um let's let's see what this let's see
where this ends
I thought her and I were on the same
team and you were the bad guy in that
situation
okay because you were short with the
phone giving it to her because this was
in the middle of you of you being
literally in left field so that's so
that's what so I was the reason you were
being short I wasn't sure when you were
like I don't want to look it up on the
phone and then she asked me for my phone
and you're like here use mine
I think we both thought your phone was
dead what no her phone was dead okay
I I don't think you're misremembering
I'm pretty sure her and I walked away
like that guy's a bozo sure because I'll
give you that's the conversation we had
in the car really
she goes what was he talking about I go
I literally I go that's fun let's throw
me under the bus because you did know
what I was talking about we were having
a conversation upstairs with Alice
seven minutes before that with other
parties involved sure but it would have
made sense what was he talking about I
would I would respond oh we were talking
to Francis House okay but that's not how
old okay sure of course obviously you
didn't do that it sold me out I mean we
I was happy we were having fun with it
you seem to be taking offense to it but
I have like a fence is the right word
I would say I just remember you're
defensive I just remember it differently
and I would say the guy was having three
different conversations with himself in
a conversation doesn't his memory might
not be as crystal clear as you proceed I
thought I was talking to my friend the
other two people in the conversation
didn't know what you were talking about
and you were talking about three
different things what does bird have to
say [ __ ]
just saying I think you've been in
foleyville a lot that's what that's how
this conversation started yeah and I
used yesterday's example
of you it was like you know beautiful
mind-esque of like it seemed like there
was a lot going on up here I'm moving
fast these days okay what's happening in
reality that's what I want to say the
wheels were spit we're cooking up here I
feel like I'm at the top of my game
right now and everywhere else in the
real world wasn't really clicked it
huh that's what I would that's my
assessment all right I could be wrong
you're both rats tell you that right now
that's how I thought her and I were on
the same team
what do you mean team
that in that I've explained this three
times to you yeah dude that was a half a
second you know we it was very Curt
okay
sure say he was Kurt he was Kurt t-bonus
he would have been there you were like
what's the deal did you end up going to
have known about the taxes and or the uh
here's the private school and or the
people at the club and or the third
thing if you buy a nice piece of
property out there in Brooklyn you still
gotta [ __ ] figure out with the
maintenance fees and all this stuff it's
it's a racket out there to be honest
with you where'd you end up going to
dinner though